YEN-JIE LEE: So to make
the demo done coherently
with your lecture,
a lot of preparation
is actually needed in advance.
So first of all,
you need to make
a list of the demo
which you would like
to include in your lecture.
And secondly, you need to work
with our technical instructors
to set up those demos
so that they work nicely
during the class.
Usually, I come to
the class, like,
half hour to one hour
before the lecture
to make sure that everything
is working as I expect.
And also there were a
lot of communication
between me and my
technical instructors
to tune the parameters
to what we would
like to demo during the
class, and to make sure
that the physical phenomena
can be seen clearly
from the demo of our choice.
And finally, you
need to decide when
do you want to do those demos.
And what you are going
to get is that, OK,
omega, omega D
around omega 0, then
you are going to get
large type amplitude.
OK?
So now, what I am going
to do is to continue--
As I mentioned
before, I usually like
to include the demo after
the calculation is done.
Sometimes maybe it's a
good idea to use the demo
as a teaser for the
calculation and see that, OK,
we can reproduce this
result by physics intuition
and mathematical calculation.
So that's actually the
kind of consideration
when I choose which kind
of demo to be included
in the lecture and the kind of
preparation before the class,
and finally, the
timing, which I decide
where to insert those
either experiments
or analytical calculation using
program during my lecture.